half of Milwaukee scoring in this series
Kevin I mentioned the six at old record
gone up top nice look offered on the
receiving end from Jason Tate a hook jab
step to the middle gets his shoulders in
front of him and Parker has nothing left
to do you see tatum going to class going
down fast she lays it up and he doesn't
cut close to them on that the coupe or
just tips it in for the Celtics it watch
this he pumps the ball away from
Middleton drives it down she's out
Horford on the corner of his eye lays it
up the steal and two points cutting to
markets bars for Horford
Jayla Brown goes by Parker gives it up
in the corner rosier got Brown what do
you have our Geo well officially jaylen
Browns
has right hamstring
[Applause]
know what to that layup
flexo has 19 he leads the Bucks Al
Horford has 20 here's Rozier counted
three quarter inch budgetary
for it's been a big part of this yeah
then I said earlier he's been rolling
hard to the rift a dangerous scoring
tandem for the Bucks Tatum trying to get
by Parker tango combative move exploding
to the glass high off the window
scores the puck and a 13-point lead
Muhammad has it back Tatum got it cut
that in balance as well market looking
for Tatum be honest asanam Tatum fires
at the three-pointer
[Applause]
that is in control do they have the
finishing kick now and Tatum spins his
way free gives it up to Rozier he lost
left toe on that coming up to the top
there for that hold for those you're
made of pay Rozier again which by the
way the last time the Bucks wanna Series
in the playoffs at oh one Tatum with the
left
[Music]
Boston keeps answering he gets in there
Parker comes over oh nice move by Terry
Rozier